I think this is wise you have jokes that
you cannot read because you're a white
male
oh yeah jokes F can't tell this came
about because they were writing jokes
that I thought were really funny and
it's a Jenny Hagel and amber Ruffin and
I would say Jenny is a great joke but I
really think that this is a joke for a
lesbian to tell and I think that it will
not be received well if I tell the joke
and she understood that but she also
didn't really want to throw away good
jokes and so they pitched this idea of
them reading jokes that I could not tell
so I read the set up and they read the
punchlines a Virginia woman was arrested
for public intoxication last week after
she was spotted carrying a suitcase with
three cats inside said lesbians three
where are the rest of our cats how many
jokes I'm responsible for and we have
probably six seven writers who are just
dedicated to writing monologue jokes
every day and they collectively probably
write 300 that we cut down to ten so it
sounds like a low number of jokes to do
you think you have to let if you just
said don't like just send your good ones
they don't know right I should say
there's a part of the day that I really
don't miss which is when we were in the
studio every day I think it was two
o'clock the entire monologue team would
come into my office and sit around and I
would read through two hundred jokes out
loud while they sat there and I would
mark the ones I liked with a highlighter
and so maybe for 200 jokes I'm marking
20 which means there are a hundred and
eighty jokes that I am basically telling
by not marking the people who wrote them
while they sit there then I do not like
them it's like you write it you're like
Kim jong-un you're killing them like it
is to comedy what pornography is to sex
it is just so workman like do the
writers laugh hard at their own jokes in
other words you hear a guy going oh you
know you like like does he tries to sell
the joke know what will happen though is
sometimes when
joke really bombs another writer will
laugh at how bad one of their
you